remember nadia sulman aka octo mom well
it's been a minute and her eight kids
look so grown up now i've always wanted
a family nadia shared this sweet new pic
of her eight youngest kids on get this
their first day of eighth grade yep
there's noah malia isaiah nariah jonah
makai josiah and jeremiah in the caption
nadia sends the octuplets some words of
advice on their big day writing quote be
proud of yourselves kids for being kind
respectful and helpful to all your
fellow peers teachers and staff you are
exceptional role models to the 6th and
7th graders i love you
[Applause]
but the year's already been full of
milestones for the octuplets they're
going to grow up they're not going to
need me anymore it's going to be totally
different that's going to be much more
stressful when they're teenagers and
that time has come nadia's kiddos
officially turned 13 in january and as
they grow older nadia is making sure
they're learning important life lessons
along the way you have thoughts that can
manifest into feelings and in turn they
can manifest into behavior right and the
way to then
take a thought that's irrational
maladaptive self-defeating is you
cognitively reframe it by william
identify challenge and change yeah
that's nadia making sure her kids are in
tune with and understand their emotions
hurt and hate how are those related does
anyone know
anyone anyone yes or no well when you
have hate it can hurt you and when
you're hurt it causes pain
but it's not just mental she's also
encouraging them to get outside and stay
active
but to fully appreciate their journey we
gotta go back to the beginning
no one not especially not me would have
ever anticipated more than one at the
most too growing it all started in 2008
when nadia made global headlines for
conceiving eight babies via ivf she gave
birth in january 2009 and sat down with
et the following month cause there's so
many positive people that have actually
come up to me and the other kids and oh
we love big families and bless you god
bless you
everyone is entitled to their own uh
perspective of life of themselves of
human behavior and who am i who is she
who is anyone to point a figure at
anyone else and judge them following
their births the kids remained in the
hospital for some time nadi invited e.t
cameras into one of her visits like hold
them and look at them and realize you
know
you know how amazing they are they're
total miracles and
i'm excited that they're going to come
home i don't have any fears really
[Music]
flash forward 13 years we love seeing
the octuplets thriving
[Music]